hi guys dr. Berg here in this video we're going
to talk about what is healthier a chicken or pork
what do you think well here's the thing it's
kind of a trick question because when you go
buy chicken commercially from the grocery store
it's highly processed and I never ever recommend
consuming that type of meat even even you know
cow me even any any of the meats I wouldn't
consume that big why because it's factory farmed
factory farmed is literally disgusting what occurs
in these factories I mean it's terrible first of
all there's GMO grains soy and corn which you're
getting a lot of pesticides from that that's
one thing right there which leads to all sorts
of health problems there's antibiotics there is
drugs that they give these animals to grow them
that are arsenic based so you're getting arsenic
it's crazy you're getting formaldehyde they use
formaldehyde to prevent Salmonella on pork
and chicken in the feed so formaldehyde is an
embalming agent you know when you die they stick
it through your veins so consuming that isn't
crazy in fact there's even an article recently
that found that like 22 different drugs in these
animals commercially like like antihistamines
and medications and you know anti like stress
drugs all this stuff that's in this meat it's
terrible so I would never consume anything like
this okay now let's differentiate over here what
you want to do is you want to get pasture-raised
products preferably from an online thing or maybe
the farmers market okay sometimes you can find
them in the health of store now that's becoming
more like pasture-raised that that means that
the pig or the chicken goes out into the grass
it actually consumes grass that's what we want
free-range doesn't really mean anything means that
they could you know walk around the barn but you
need to get past raise the same same thing with
chicken eggs from a small farmer okay that's the
ideal scene that's what you need to do because if
you saw what happens to this it'll just make you
you know vomit it's so terrible they used you
want to get non-gmo now how do you know it's
non-gmo well it's going to have is going to say
organic so if it's organic it's non-gmo that way
you don't get the the grains that are genetically
modified you want no antibiotics no hormones so
when you go to the store and you at the grocery
store and it says no antibiotics it's natural
that's not what we're doing and that's not the
same that's just one of the things you're looking
for okay no nitrates if you're buying bacon like
no nitrates nitrates are like a chem oppressor vut
if you want to get no nitrates you want to get
the Paleo bacon that has like no sugar added so
those are some of the things but this is the most
important pasture raised right here I'm going to
put some links down below where you can research
and find some of this is it more expensive yes is
it healthier absolutely it's so healthy but this
stuff here you have to start phasing out of this
because this is very unhealthy right here so it
was a little bit of a trick question but both
of these are bad unless you're doing this now
personally I prefer more pork now why because
it's fattier it's a fattier meat it's not as
lean now if you have chicken there's skin on
it right I don't think you're going to do the
skin on the pork unless it's a these pork rinds
but the chicken actually provides some fat
the skin so that would be fine but the pork
is fattier and if you're doing trying to actually
lose weight and do a ketogenic diet you want more
fat in the diet because the lean meats actually
stimulate insulin more than the fattier meats
so pork would be better on your insulin levels if
you're either pre-diabetic or insulin resistance
than a chicken but I know people think oh yeah
chicken is really healthy yeah not quite but
if you actually have it pasture raised it's
actually pretty healthy alright I hope that
cleared up some confusion I'm sure I stir up some
controversy but it's below thanks for watching